do I look like I'm 21 and I don't give a
[ __ ] hello guys and welcome to my truck
stop it is stream-of-consciousness
extreme of vlogs justice is that a word
can we make it a word to weave that
power strength in numbers
that's mathematical right 100 is clearly
better than 1 or is it when it comes to
like racing golf when it comes to
bowling numbers are anyway another day
another hotel room I have been shooting
a lot of stuff but did you think I was
gonna sneeze a burp it's just a mouth
sneeze or a mouth fart maybe a sneeze
it's just a nose burp or a nose bar
maybe a fart it's just a butt sneeze or
but burp this is like math I have been
shooting all weekend footage for a
secret project that will be announced
this week yeah and I can't tell you
anything about it and I hope nothing in
the background is spoilers
it's about bedsheets holy [ __ ] did I
give it away I'm gonna put a sheet over
the blanket they're crazy
that's like having an icing cake covered
in cake batter they're crazy
this is a stream of consciousness flood
which means I'm just gonna talk about
what's in my brain hey that's worth your
zero dollars of entertainment right to
the moon if it exists I like things that
are labeled exactly what they are
there's also an armoire here who has
ever use the armoire in their hotel room
why is it called an armoire doesn't the
arm work thanks it's an ironing board
told you I like things like but exactly
what they are here's a jumping on the
bed to tour this is called the I panic
last minute didn't know what I was doing
oh and there you go this one is called
the are you still talking
this one's called I thought I saw
sneaking the bed mid-jump onto the bed
hey Chad watch this I'm super cool watch
this and there you go there's a quick
tutorial about jumping on your bed are
you following the world cup the face
paint industry just must love sports so
much in America the red white and blue
face paint companies must be like yes
please keep going and FIFA and then when
they lost they must have been like well
that's all I guess go back into
accounting I ain't clamps today
metaphor no I had a small epiphany in
the last couple days that stains matter
people form opinions on you based on the
stains on your shirt
so I bought a stain stick have I used it
no to the moon if it exists people
wanting to anuses do they [ __ ] somewhat
aeneas say it word its it so you know
I'm gonna go wrong do that maybe new
here I wrote a book can you believe this
idiot
got the opportunity to write a book I
know what idiots that let me do that for
you idiots but I did it's available for
free so great and I would love for you
guys to purchase it because I'm almost
completely finished we're just tweaking
the final things now and I am I'm really
excited about this I don't be arrogant
so I'll just say if you would like a
softcover manuscript of diarrhea of
Burbidge please invest I don't know
VidCon starts this Thursday Friday ish
so are you going let me know if not I'm
sorry I'm sorry
too soon grace this guy book.com